dans les environs de la base militaire
de guedjtown les chars d'assaut font
partie du paysage et aussi de la mémoire
de la communauté
ce sergent à la retraite se rappelle où
il s'installait sur cet ancien chars
centurion de l'armée canadienne au cours
de sa carrière certaines opérations
l'ont marqué oui
de Charles canadien en Bosnie pour le
métier de la paix dans les années 90 à
guedjtown un autre déploiement se
prépare de quoi remplir de fiertés ce
vétérans
à l'aube la base se réveille au
rugissement d'un léopard le dernier des
quatre chars promis à l'Ukraine par
Ottawa s'apprête à quitter le Canada
bientôt des militaires Ukrainiens
remplaceront les Canadiens aux commandes
ce Canadien ont eu peu de temps pour
préparer cette énorme colis on parle de
14 jours quand l'annonce a été faite
l'identification à travers la flotte
parfois la préparation de matériel de
guerre une centaine de militaires sont
impliqués l'opération de transport est
complexe on parle d'un véhicule de 62
tonnes voyez sur la remorque en arrière
de moi c'est au-dessus de 33 mètres les
Forces canadiennes disposent de 82 chars
de combat léopard mais les responsables
militaires ne veulent pas dire combien
sont fonctionnels est prêt au combat
chose certaine l'inventaire est limitée
les quatre qui sont envoyés servaient à
de la formation ici sur la base
militaire de guedjtown
l'énergie est très haut à savoir que
nous participons à envoyer du matériel
de guerre qui va être utilisé et
apporter du succès à nos alliés en
Ukraine le confrères du crinière
l'esprit les militaires canadiens ne
perdent pas une seconde
sur la route entre la base de guedjstein
et l'aéroport d'Halifax le léopard est
loin de passer inaperçu
l'équipement qui a servi pendant le
conflit en Afghanistan atlage mais les
charges occidentaux changeons la donne
en Ukraine assure ce colonel puissance
de feu direct incroyable on parle de
mobilité sous champ de bataille c'est
une course contre la montre on redoute
le déclenchement d'une vaste offensive
russe au cours des prochaines semaines
dans l'est de l'Ukraine la seule façon
que répondre à ça c'est pas par une
masse de personnes de leur côté s'ils
l'ont déjà maximisé mais c'est pas des
moyens techniques qui vont être de leur
donner l'avantage sur le terrain
Richard sont expédiés à l'aide d'un C17
canadien
en raison de leur poids la livraison
jusqu'en Europe n'est qu'une première
étape le Canada devra envoyer des pièces
de rechange et des munitions des
militaires canadiens seront aussi
appelés à former des soldats Ukrainiens
il faut apprendre à les opérer mais
aussi les entretenir les chars d'assaut
sont des machines complexes et
capricieux
nous avions l'habitude de dire pour deux
heures d'utilisation il faut 8 heures
d'entretien soulignent le vétéran
teri-michaley il a formé des équipages
de char au Canada à ses yeux le plus
important pour les soldats Ukrainiens
sera l'esprit d'équipe à bord
pour survivre ils devront travailler
ensemble dit-il
si la contribution canadienne peut
sembler modeste en comparaison des
centaines de chars promis par les Alliés
qui investissent chaque pièce
d'équipements supplémentaires peut faire
la différence sur le champ de bataille
ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada Halifax